sur les conclusions que je vais vous
présenter que vous avez déjà vu
mais
elles sont elles reprennent plus ou
moins les conclusions de la rencontre
informelle à brest
la militarisation
dans et autour de l'ukraine la tentative
russe de recréer des lignes de division
sur notre continent je sape les
fondations et les principes clés sur
lesquels repose la sécurité européenne
ils nous rappellent à des périodes
sombres
la période des sphères d'influencé qui
n'a pas sa place au 21e siècle nous
réaffirmons
notre soutien plein et certains à
l'ukraine
toute agression militaire contre
l'ukraine aura des conséquences
sérieuses et sera payé au prix fort par
le perpétrateurs
nous avons eu un long échange avec le
secrétaire blinken
s'il a été particulièrement utile pour
évaluer la voit venir pour les états
unis et l'union européenne
nous continuerons à maintenir une
coordination très étroite avec notre
partenaire comme nous l'avons fait tout
au long de ce processus
l'union européenne n'est pas absente des
négociations des pourparlers avec la
russie
avant et après les rencontres
nous nous coordonnions nos discussions
nous étions informés et nous les
informions auprès des états unis j'ai eu
des appels individuels et collectifs
avec le temps et les états unis afin
d'être pleinement informés de ce qui se
passait
trois éléments principaux nous guideront
à l'avenir
tout d'abord nos efforts diplomatiques
collectif afin de convaincre la russie
d'adopter la fois du dialogue se
poursuivront
avec
même si le discours russe ne vous
inspire pas grande confiance
les ministres m'ont demandé de continuer
à coordonner la position de l'union
européenne avec tous nos partenaires
clés donc l'otan et les états unis
afin d'assurer l'efficacité de nos
efforts nous demandons à la russie de
continuer à mener at
à prendre part aux mécanismes établis au
sein par exemple de l'oas et nous devons
également continuer les efforts pour
réactiver le processus de normandie le
processus format non dits et afin de
mettre en oeuvre les accords de minsk
nous restons en contact auprès de nos
partenaires internationaux afin
d'expliquer ce qui se passe dans l'union
européenne
afin d'éclaircir les désinformations
disséminées par la russie
nous devons renforcer notre
communication stratégique pour lutter
contre cette désinformation et je vous
invite
à jeter un oeil aux réseaux contre la
désinformation européen qui déboulonne à
certains discours dangereux répandue
aujourd'hui
vous y trouverez l'explication des trois
mythes que la russie propage à propos de
la situation à la frontière ukrainienne
deuxièmement si la diplomatie échoue et
nous ferons de notre mieux pour que la
diplomatie fonctionne mais si la
diplomatie échoue
nous sommes avancées dans la préparation
de réaction à des agressions potentiel
russe
il s'agira d'une action rapide et
déterminée
c'est au sein non seulement de l'union
européenne mais également au niveau
international
troisièmement
nous devons renforcer nos efforts afin
de détailler la résilience de l'ukraine
et de nos autres partenaires il existe
des actions concrètes que nous pouvons
prendre et que nous croyons le président
de la commission la présidente de la
commission a annoncé aujourd'hui un
paquet de mesures d' aide afin de
soutenir l'ukraine au moyen et à long
terme
nous doublons nos
soutiens financiers
et nous mettons à disposition
mille millions d'euros de manière
d'urgence voire même plus d'ailleurs je
pense
1,2 non
c'est une somme très importante
mon collègue le commissaire oliver se
rendra en ukraine afin de l'annoncé et
de rentrer en contact avec les autorités
craignent elles
nous étudions d'autres manières de
soutenir les craintes dans un autre
domaine clé contre les cyber menaces
nous avons rapidement condamine et
condamner les cyberattaques d'il ya dix
jours nous étions prêts à aider
l'ukraine laventie à brest
il s'agissait là d'une preuve de notre
capacité à agir nous sommes prêts à
répondre à toute autre attaque de ce
genre et nous continuerons à renforcer
la résilience face notamment à la
manipulation de l'information
nous sommes prêts à mobiliser une
mission afin de soutenir l'ukraine dans
la lutte contre les cyber attaques
les états membres mettront à disposition
des ressources qui seront coordonnées si
besoin par l'union européenne en
matière de sécurité de défense j'ai déjà
mentionné les 35 millions d'euros lui à
disposition afin de renforcer les
capacités de l'armée ukrainienne nous
intensifions notre travail sur l'idée
d'une mission d'assistance européenne en
ukraine afin de former les militaires et
j'espère que la décision sera prise
rapidement
de notre côté nous continuerons à
accélérer nos efforts de préparation
en amont d'une éventuelle décision
nous devons rester en contact étroit
avec nos partenaires dans la région et
être très clair sur le fait que
renforcer la résilience interne fondée
sur une démocratie est important afin de
pouvoir réagir face aux menaces
extérieures
nous encourageons donc l'ukraine 1 a
continué son travail sur les réformes en
cours
dernier point mais non le moindre je
souhaite souligner que nous sommes unis
dans nos positions une autre unité et
notre force la plus importante
nous avons évoqué la syrie nous avons
évoqué la libye nous avons évoqué le
mali nous avons évoqué le burkina faso
je souhaite évoquer rapidement le mali
et le burkina faso
et je vais passer en français car la
france est profondément impliquée dans
ce processus reste des décisions prises
par les autorités maliennes de proposer
une transition des quatre ans ainsi que
le déploiement de navires et vérifier
les compagnies banner ne sont pas
acceptables pour nous casser des os et
cedeao a adopté des sanctions
économiques et financières
et nous travaillons dans ces lignes il
va se tenir une réunion les prochains bc
jambiers avec les ministres des affaires
étrangères de 10,5 sel est j'espère
avoir l'occasion de discuter avec eux et
en particulier avec les ministres du
mali
aucune décision sera prise avant que
cette réunion les tiennent pas lieu et
j'espère que cette occasion de nous
rencontrer va ne m'étonnait
l'opportunité de faire passer des
messages et de consolider notre prochain
sur le burkina faso
nous savons le suivant avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude
l'évolution de la situation au burkina
faso les dernières nouvelles sont très
préoccupantes en faisant état de
détentions du président kaboré j
d'inoccupation de la radio télévision
nationale par des éléments de l'armée
hier je parle avec des ministres
affaires étrangères du burkina faso et
le président du conseil européen a parlé
de la président du burkina faso la
situation semblait sous contrôle
pendant la journée d'aujourd'hui
les nouvelles ont été bien pire mauvaise
et nous savons maintenant que les plus
encadrées et sous le contrôle de l'armée
nous appelons au respect à l'ordre
constitutionnel est la libération de
plus il encadrait
si on l'assuré
on a discuté de la procédure que le
spécial spécialement et des nations
unies voudrait suivre des step by step
mais tous les états membres étaient
d'accord et tant qu'il n'y aura pas un
engagement politique des régimes la sat
il y aura pas ou qui ne reconnaissant
aucune communication aucun travail qui
sera fait ensemble à part de l'aide
humanitaire au peuple
siri qui va être remonté en suivant les
plans que nous a présenté l'envoyé
spécial des nations unies
et je pense qu'avec ça c'est peut-être
suffisant pour pour donner l'occasion de
poser vos questions merci beaucoup
de roms
le trouverez le microphone
dans les allées de la salle présentez
vous s'il vous plaît et quant aux
récollets qu'à l'écran vous pouvez
également levé la main première question
pour le allgemeine zeitung
monsieur le représentant je suis ici
lorsque vous avez pris lorsque vous vous
rendiez ton conseil vous disiez que vous
vous attendiez à ce que le secrétaire
d'état monsieur bloqués explique
pourquoi il avait décidé
de commencer l'évacuation de l'ambassade
à kiev vous avez également dit
que toute décision du côté européen
dépendrez à tous il y avait des raisons
suffisantes ma question est la suivante
avez vous entendu des raisons
suffisantes pour que les ambassades
pride est une mesure de précaution
maintenant les mesures de précaution
recouvre toute une série de réactions
par exemple fermer la porte lorsqu'on
quitte à maison
je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas prendre
de mesures de précaution mais le début
de l'évacuation c'est une autre chose
il s'agit d'une mesure de précaution
très précise
le secrétaire blinken jeu nous a dit
qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'une évacuation
il a fort mais simplement les gens
ils informaient simplement les personnes
qui ne faisait pas partie du personnel
clé
qu'il pouvait décider de quitter le pays
s'ils le souhaitaient il ne s'agissait
donc pas d'une évacuation
deuxièmement après des échanges entre
nous après avoir partagé les
informations dont nous disposons et
après avoir écouté les arguments du
secrétaire blinken je ne pense pas
qu'il soit nécessaire de prendre des
mesures de précaution
concernant nos personnels et nos
permanences en ukraine
aux questions suivantes en ligne tu vas
finir en poste angéla nous vous ouvrons
le micro
merci de cette occasion c'est sur le
même sujet monsieur blinken vous at il
demandé
de prendre des mesures de précaution
quelles ont été les réactions des états
membres y at il une unité sur cette
question également
comme je les dis il ne s'agissait pas
d'une évacuation
il s'agissait simplement d'annoncer au
personnel non essentiel qu'il pouvait
partir s'il le souhaitait
donc il ne s'agit pas d'une évacuation
même au niveau de cette mesure basse de
précaution très basse je pense que nous
sommes tous d'accord au niveau des états
membres pour dire que même cette mesure
de précaution n'est pas nécessaire
une question dans la salle hague a souri
je suis le représentant j'ai des
questions concernant la russie pour
d'abord
cela fait déjà trois mois
que le conseil se rassemblent et le
conseil parle d'accélérer le travail
préparatoire concernant des sanctions en
cas d' attaques de la russie ma question
est la suivante pourquoi cela prend at
il tant de temps
et quand peut-on s'attendre à ce que
vous soyez prêts pour des
pour des sanctions qu'est-ce qui prend 6
dans la tête ou les sanctions non et
pourquoi cela vous prend du temps de
temps pour compléter des mesures de
représailles deuxième question l'union
européenne
ne dit vu le jeu pas quels seraient les
sanctions et je comprends pourquoi
mais l'union européenne
lee n'a mentionné aucune sanction et
cela donne une très large marge de
manoeuvre à l'union européenne pour
infliger que des sanctions très
symbolique a donc ma question est la
suivante
comment
imaginez vous convaincre monsieur
poutine la direction les les autorités
russes 1
qu'il y aurait à des sanctions fortes et
un coût élevé à toute action
un élément de la situation c'est de ne
pas donner toute l'information
ne vous inquiétez pas les mesures seront
prises et mises en oeuvre au moment
approprié
si il arrive qu'une extrême merci
question suivante via zoom
votre micro devrait être ouvert
merci peter
question si je le peux à la fin du tout
d'abord le secrétaire blake n at il
évoqué aujourd'hui les négociations de
vendredi à genève où la situation sur le
terrain qui aurait modifié votre opinion
d'une façon ou d'une autre concernant la
probabilité d'une attaque russe
en ukraine
deuxièmement la des ministres des
affaires étrangères monsieur rakovic de
lettonie
évoqué l'idée d'une militarisation en
biélorussie contre à proximité de la
frontière batik qui serait une menace
non seulement envers l'ukraine mais
également envers le temps est également
une de vos préoccupations merci
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'entretenir avec
monsieur blinken de manière bilatérale
et avec d'autres personnes d'autres
institutions telles que l'otan avant et
après chacune de leurs rencontres avec
les russes
nous n'avons rien appris de neuf
aujourd'hui car nous avions déjà reçu
l'information directement de monsieur
blinken
immédiatement avant ou après les
rencontres
ce n'était pas le cas de mes collègues
car ils n'étaient pas tous en contact
avec monsieur blinken sort était
impossible nous sommes 27
les vingt-sept et moi même nous étions
donc rassemblés pour écouter des
explications de monsieur blinken mais à
cela ne m'a rien apporté de nafi n'a
rien dit de neuf par rapport aux
informations qu'il avait déjà communiqué
donc je ne pense pas qu'une information
puisse du milieu d'hommes augmenté le
niveau de préoccupation concernant une
attaque immédiate concernant la menace
que pourrait représenter la menace de la
présence de troupes russes en
biélorussie non seulement envers
l'ukraine mais en verre par exemple à
lithuania la lituanie je ne le pense pas
non plus
nous prenons question suivante de
philippe voilà
merci bien philippe régnier du journal
le soir trois questions si je peux mais
rapide tout d'abord effectivement
concernant l'alarmisme dont vous avez
parlé à l'entrée ici en disant qu' il
n'était pas l'heur d'être trop alarmiste
est-ce que de la conversation avec le
secrétaire d'état blinken vous avez une
idée du calendrier de la poursuite des
négociations des discussions
diplomatiques
au delà de cette semaine est ce que ça
va peut se poursuivre dans le courant du
mois de février sur les préparatifs des
sanctions on a souvent parlé de
la coordination avec des partenaires on
cite vous citez régulièrement les états
unis le royaume uni le canada est ce que
cette coordination est cette possibilité
d'adopter des sanctions pourrait
s'élargir à d'autres états de la planète
ces pages le japon laddh pourquoi pas je
pose la question à boko voilà et
troisième petite question le ministre
roumain si je ne m'abuse des affaires
étrangères a suggéré la tenue d'un
conseil des affaires étrangères à kiev
dans un avenir assez proche en signe de
solidarité avec l'ukraine est ce que
vous pensez que c'est une une option
merci beaucoup oui mais vous vois bien
informée
oui
oui ça a été une des propositions de la
mission la table pourquoi pas ses parts
c'est pas impossible à cause des
affaires étrangères et statuant à
l'unanimité peut décider de se réunir au
siège
donc c'est des circonstances le
demandent et si il y à un accord unanime
on pourrait très bien se réunir
n'importe où et pourquoi par kiev céda
situation s'aggraver et ça devait être
une façon de montrer une fois son
collectif si chacun de nous en montrer
et qui est collectivement si on a montré
ici à à bruxelles ou à brest où la
solidarité et l'engagement avec luc l'un
d'eux mais rien n'a été décidé là dessus
alors vous devez savoir s'il ya d'autres
pays avec lesquels on coordonne
au niveau de l'union européenne la
coordination se passe avec les états
unis certainement vers les canaries à
belgrade le royaume uni
et qu'elle était la première question
parce que je vois
c'est est sûre le l'alarmisme donc vous
avez dû à l'entrée qu'il devrait même
tomber dedans et demander si de la
conversation avec monsieur blinken la
perspective de discussions d'ordre
diplomatique pouvait aller au delà de
cette semaine qui s'ouvre maintenant
n'est pas mendier
écoute écoute et je pense qu'il faut
il faut pas laisser comme jouer avec nos
nerfs ve
peut-être il ya des gens qui veulent
être jouée de nos nerfs je pense qu'il
ne faut pas jouer à ça
nous on sait très bien que sont les
menace et on sait très bien que les
écrits des menaces et on sait très bien
dans la façon qu'il faut réagir il s'en
doute il faut éviter des réactions qui
peuvent
donnez les sens d'une alarme qui a des
conséquences
même du produit financier donc il faut
rester tranquille en faisant ce qu'il
faut faire mais en évitant de incluse
l'énervent
le calendrier
on est en train d etats unis sont
atteints de répondre par écrit
à la demande de la russie
nous a eu l'occasion de connaître la
demande de la connaît puisque les
publics mais on a eu l'occasion de
discuter les termes de la réponse je dis
ça parce que souvent je je lis dans la
presse dans les moyens que
l'européenne en dehors ne participe pas
elle n'est pas là la table
tout à fait dans le court on a suivi pas
à pas les négociations n'a été consulté
et on a été consultée même pour préparer
la réponse ruche
pour répondre à faire les états unis et
l'otan que sont sertis la russie la rade
et mende et une fois que se répondent
sert à envoyer par a écrit comme le
russe l'ont demandé dire qu'ils font des
études d'étudier imagine que l'écho
lundi va dépendre des thés sa réponse ne
pouvait pas anticiper quelle sera sa
réponse
merci une excursion
prochaine à distance de rosie rausis
votre micro est ouvert vous posez poser
la question merci beaucoup
l'oci peut achète de features news
j'avais une question pour vous vous
voulez
lancer un message fort vous parlez
beaucoup d'unités mais
des indices laisse penser qu'il y a des
divergences au sein à 10k membres par
exemple concernant l'exportation des
armes vers l'ukraine avez vous évoqué
ces sujets
pensez vous qu'un manque d'unité pour
est à vous à faiblir face à la russie
merci
au sein de l'union européenne les états
membres se rassemblent afin d'évoquer
les compétences que nous avons en commun
nous ne discutons pas de tout ce que
fait chaque état membre de son côté donc
cela n'a pas été évoqué
j'avais deux petites questions en
français sur le mali bon c'est tout
d'abord vous
vous avez évoqué l'idée de sanctions
qui serait reporté selon ce que j'ai
bien compris à la rencontre avec le
ministre malien des affaires étrangères
mercredi qu'est ce que vous attendez du
ministre malien pour ne pas faire tomber
le couperet des de ces sanctions là
je voulais savoir également si on en
aparté du coup il n'y aura pas de
représentant du burkina faso à cette
réunion où est ce qu'il y aura la
ministre des affaires étrangères je
dirais du gouvernement actuel et
deuxième petite question vous avez parlé
d'une proposition un peu plus tôt le
président macron et parler une
proposition européenne sur l'
architecture de sécurité que les
européens étaient en train de rédiger
peut-être que j'ai mal compris ce cas ce
qu'a dit le président macron mais est ce
que c'est cette proposition européenne
est en train d'être rédigé ou est ce que
c'est en fait votre contribution à la
réponse américaine qui se trouve être la
proposition européenne ou est ce qu'on
doit attendre une espèce de
contre-propositions européenne aux
propositions oui merci beaucoup
vous n'avez pas à vous excuser vous par
des français
vous n'avez pas à vous excuser c'est une
langue officielle de l'union européenne
et je suis ravi de pouvoir
l'employé dans cette conférence de
presse
voyons
sans sion
la cde et la communauté des états
africains
l'afrique de l'ouest a plus des
sanctions très importante très du livre
vis à vis du mali
avant ça nous avions approuvé un cadre
juridique
pour appliquer des sanctions parce que
vous savez que l'union européenne a
besoin d'un cadre juridique on est très
formel le thé légale des façons que les
sanctions soient
contestable devant les tribunaux ces
besoins ni les cadres juridiques étaient
approuvés mais pour l'instant il n'a pas
été appliqué il y a des propositions qui
ont été discutées dans le groupe de
travail
le conseil n'était pas aujourd'hui à
condition de prendre une décision parce
que de travail la vie est finie il pas
de vis de la procédure tant que surtout
de conseil n'a pris aucune décision
évidemment il n'en parlera pas t'es sûr
mercredi même s'il voulait signer cette
ça serait pas possible en tenant compte
de procédure mais je pense honnêtement
que si j'habite délivre les ministres
mal et allégée du pression à bruxelles
ça ne serait la meilleure façon de les
recevoir des abeilles les sanctionner
louis autres membres de son gouvernement
donc on va attendre la volonté politique
d'appliquer des sanctions à l'appui ce
qu'on a approuvé un cadre juridique
c'est pas ses clés mais je pense que de
la volonté était de l'avoir écrite en
cours doit être
de façon cohérente avec le contact
diplomatique nous sommes en train de
développer avec les pays du sahel cinq
pays du sahel
les malices et par mieux donc j'espère
avoir une conversation encore une autre
jeune fille plusieurs avec les ministres
des sept pays du sahel et en particulier
vers ministre du mali pour savoir
quelles sont ses intentions du point de
vue des déploiements de troupes à
désir de bruges mais je m'en fait deux
compagnies banner et quelles sont ses
intentions par rapport à la capacité de
la mission mais tellement militaires que
nous entretenons que nous continuons à
voir au mali le déploiement de la
capacité d'agir des forces
que la france et ses alliés on mali
refonte générale qu'elle est là la
situation les perspectives et c'est
évident que
cette quatre ans de transition
pour cent à 4 ans les élections qui
étaient promises pour la fin de l'année
c'est quelque chose qui a poussé à ses
torts et à prendre des mesures et la
mienne européenne doit aussi en prendre
mais avant il faut discuter avec les
invités jeudi prochain
c'est tout le temps de disposer merci
beaucoup merci aux interprètes et bonne
soirée au revoir
[Musique]